Karuna virus is the biggest challenge of
our lifetimes and the measures we take
to tackle it must reflect the magnitude
of that these measures are essential to
slow down the spread of this virus they
are essential to reduce the peak impact
of it they are essential to prevent our
National Health Service being
overwhelmed so that it can continue to
provide treatment to all of those who
need it and they are quite bluntly
essential to save lives
so I asked you not to think that any of
this is being done lately it is
absolutely not
this is for the protection of each and
every one of us so what i am telling
people across Scotland that they know
you must do to help us fight this virus
is stay at home that is the clear
message I gave yesterday and I am
reinforcing that message now from
tonight the only permissible reasons to
leave your home are as follows
firstly to show up for basic necessities
and I'm asking that you should limit
that to once a day second to take
exercise again once a day but to do so
alone or with your own household not in
groups third for medical reasons or to
care for a vulnerable person and
fourthly to travel to essential work if
that work cannot be done at home as I
said earlier today we will be issuing
further guidance to employers to help
them judge what is and is not essential
and of course support is in place for
businesses and the employees and more I
hope will be put in place for those who
are self-employed